let's go to the big analysis on video
let's play it thank you all so much for
coming here today is a gigantic day in
my life obviously my first press
conference will signs about it and we're
having this to announce that as of today
I am officially retiring from the NFL
although I love Jim Irsay in the
Indianapolis Colts organization I want
to turn my focus to making the world a
happier place with more laughs as
opposed to just kicking a ball on fourth
downs every once in a while if the
glorious day I'm real excited is opening
up for questions
Adam in this area who's going to hold my
balls for me that's a really good
question
just like in everything in the NFL is
coming over you know it's the business
and they'll find a younger more
attractive me a better me to hold your
ball straight out of college or well
it'll be great you know you're the best
person has ever held my balls I take
that as a gigantic compliment was it
something I did
no no I don't want you to think that at
all I know that you know you're the goat
and all these things was probably an
insecurity because but it wasn't you
managed to get any other questions
Greg Olson just to clarify I've been to
many of press conferences in my day
there's zero press here we just
clarifying this was just a conference or
what exactly is going on today Oh Greg
thank you when are we trying to ruin the
whole day but this is a press copy I'm
answering question which goddamn podium
right behind me and I didn't like the
phone and Ian Rapoport NFL Network ah go
yourself Greg oh yeah great to see
you Ian I thought this is the Roger
Goodell pressure hello
any other question just again to clarify
or we back to just considering this a
conference we still get a hang on the
press what exactly we still moving
forward how okay let's go on with my
friend I'm at this very thing cozy the
point has been proven here I'm retiring
from the NFL billing in the
entertainment industry thank you all so
much for coming a great day
even though Greg Olson driver really so
thank you all so much for coming
but that's where are you going I'm
joining the most powerful stores and
entertainment media and I can't wait to
be a full time staff member or for parts
for chemically empty parcel New York are
you aware just how bad it is really a
million dollars a career yes Lord yon
blog that is stupid
yep next question all right let's bring
them out bring out
[Applause]
so